Speaker 1: . I received the video from a concerned
citizen, one of our viewers in and I think
it's pronounced dought, then maybe Dothan,
Alabama.
Marjorie Taylor Green was in Alabama about
10 days ago at an event at which filming was
not allowed.
But our viewer, this concerned citizen, surreptitiously
filmed.
And in this event sponsored by the Alabama
Federation of Republican Women, Marjorie Taylor
Green was the keynote speaker.
She suggests shooting vaccinators if indeed
people start coming door to door offering
vaccines.
This is a sitting member of Congress.
This is video provided exclusively to us.
Take a look at this.
Take a listen to this.
Speaker 5: And one more thing on that.
You lucky people here in Alabama might get
a knock on your door because I here in Alabama
might be one of the most unvaccinated states
in the nation.
Speaker 1: Guys, they're cheering for being
unvaccinated.
They're cheering for being unvaccinated.
They're cheering because they haven't been
vaccinated.
Speaker 5: Well, Joe Biden wants to come talk
to you guys.
He's going to be sending one of his police,
state friends to your front door.
Speaker 1: I call them nurses, you know, police,
state friends.
I would I would call them nurses
Speaker 5: on the door, take down your name,
your address, your family member's names,
your phone numbers, your cell phone numbers.
Probably ask for your Social Security number
and whether you take the vaccine or not.
Yeah, well, what they don't know is in the
South, we all love our Second Amendment rights.
Speaker 1: Can you imagine being
Speaker 5: a stranger showing up on our front
door when
Speaker 1: we're big on our Second Amendment
rights and we're not big on strangers showing
up at our front door?
This is a sitting member of Congress joking
about the idea.
I mean, is it a joke, I guess is the question
alluding to the idea of if people come around
offering vaccines to keep us safe, to reduce
the chance that we die, guns would be what
are deployed against those individuals, a
sitting member of Congress.
So thanks to our viewer who is asked to remain
anonymous, who filmed this surreptitiously,
again, that was July.
Twenty third in Dothan, Alabama.
It was an event actually that Mo Brooks also
was their Mo Brooks is the guy who, despite
saying that the January 6th insurrection was
no big deal, we found out he was wearing body
armor that day.
He also spoke at this event and absolutely
horrifying.
Spread the video far and wide.
We do want to make sure as many people as
possible see that